yes you're now live chair
thank you uh welcome members of the
harbour board and the public who are
watching on youtube
to this meeting of the biddeford harbour
board
you'll find it's a relatively informal
meeting but we hope to get through the
business for not too much hassle and too
long
we'll deal with item one apologies for
absence
you chair i haven't received any
apologies for absence
right but we have got a couple who are
missing
item two are the minutes of the meeting
of the 17th of september
we'll go through them for accuracy first
starting reading from the bottom on page
three four
five six
seven eight
nine she will
take a vote as to whether we're happy
with those to be recorded
as a true and accurate record
ready kirsty yeah can we have a proposal
one second to please first i'll propose
i'll second
thank you chair councillor hicks for
councillor mcgoff
councillor christie or councillor james
or councillor rossi or
mr gibbs oh mr hardaker
oh that's unanimous chair
thank you we now move on to
agenda item three is the
action list
so on page 10 minute number
3 meeting of the 10th of october
work for the harbour master there any
comments paul
paul you're muted the port health uh
um chairman
well janet williams has been in um in
contact with uh councillor christie
and um i think they're satisfied that
that's been completed
chairman they weren't able to get to the
bottom of um
the issue and uh i want to close down
now so
if councillor christie's in agreement
with that
yes uh i'm afraid it goes back to uh
history that one
well you would know all about it
minute number ten
an economy magic manager that would be
for sean and he ain't present
i think isn't it
uh yes sir and that's uh um
we've had no fees from medicine users
group
we are happy to meet them as and when um
they get in contact with us
so it's uh an ongoing action chairman
okay thank you and
item 17 another one again for sean on
speed limits yeah that's again that's
ongoing um
um with the planning economy manager and
uh
we have something to come back for next
summer chairman it'll be
there's not a great deal going on the
river in terms of leisure users at the
moment so that will bring that will be
that'll be um
completed for next semester
fun job item eight i think is in obeying
that can be dropped off the list at this
stage can it
um it is an obeyance uh chairman but it
is something that we
have been discussing at a management
level and we are still
we have got some stakeholders are still
interested
in pursuing this project so um if we
could keep it on the list it's something
that it's under consideration
um with with richard hayes and myself
chairman
fair enough item 37
uh supposed to be an informal meeting i
don't recall having heard about one
no chairman that's something that's
still with sean carney um and we're
waiting for him to uh
to pick up on that one sir if key can be
reminded please
yes sir we'll do that item
42 i confirm that i did send a letter
of appreciation to the crane driver
last week
okay we move on
next one is items
brought forward by permission of the
chairman
and this is where we're going to bring
in uh mr buddy's letter
uh do you want uh
richard to read the letter mr puddy or
would you like to
take it straight through i'm very happy
to take it straight through if that's
all right
[Music]
fine
okay so um it's uh
okay there are points in the points of
consideration
um in the policy um
and it was really proposals regarding
the
facilities for visiting yachts and i was
asked to put in
my my thoughts in writing as part of the
consultation
um one there are a couple of points
which i mean i'm talking from the
perspective of the chamber of commerce
obviously very interested in tourism and
the promotion of the area
and one of the area one of the issues
which i thought was of concern are
regulations that um
have been put in place by the authority
one of which is that customers are not
expected to sleep on board their craft
whilst birthed in the harbor unless that
vessel has a suitable holding tank
basically that makes it very difficult
if not
impossible for touring vessels to uh
to to visit biddeford as um there is no
um recognized pump facility in the port
um and even for a vessel with with a
holding tank there's um
there's no means that tank for bessel
vessels burn
birth for the long term again no
facility making it very difficult for
any liver board vessel
um the toilets as far as i'm aware host
at night and therefore
facilities are limited um what i was
suggesting that could be possibly
possibly considered is a dedicated
marine
facility for small boats such as a
toilet
and a shower which is common in a lot of
places where a key is actually given
to the um to the birth holder for the
duration of the stay
and though and showers and toilets are
available
so an ideal solution would be
a pontoon for visitors which would have
to hook up electricity water and an easy
walk to the toilet
another possible way forward for the
short term is to consider
utilizing the disabled toilets and
providing access
to that toilet during her overnight
periods
i i feel that um
the the harbor isn't really marketed
in a positive sense and i've been trying
to look up
visiting biddeford on google various
sites and there's nothing
[Music]
really that there's anyone to come here
whilst on a sailing tour or even
um it doesn't even promote anything
particularly
attractive about the port and i think
given that it's a heritage port we ought
to
really start what what benefits there
are for people coming into
um into the town
the other um the other issue which i'm
i was the cancellation of the facility
form agreement
where it says the avoidance of a doubt
the harbour master has delegated
responsibility to terminate the
facility agreements on behalf of the
council
this was a rather sort of draconian way
of proceeding which
actually created an element of
vulnerability
both for the harbour master as an
employee of the council
and uh visitors or permanent birth
holders
i felt there should be some mechanism
which enabled people to
uh to appeal or to move forward for
example if the hardware master
really struggles to resolve an issue
it's always very handy to be able to
start
i'm back and i'll take this to the
council we'll come back to you
it gives some sort of maneuvering
opportunity
so these are the points i wanted to just
bring to the meeting
thank you mr paddy um
the first part of it contains in my
opinion
two questions one what is the likely
cost of providing said facilities
and two what is the likely
of number of boats to use it and i say
that because all the television programs
i see
they sail up and down the south coast
you don't see them sailing the north
coast
that i just wonder whether we'd be
spending a lot of money
for not too many customers
the second part is going to be one for
stacy i would think but
could it be rewritten would there be
benefits in that the harbour board has
the power to do
things but it delegates to the harbour
master
the day-to-day function thereof
would you like me to respond chair
sorry i think paul wants to come in and
pull up love yeah so i'll let him
talk okay let paul i don't need to say
on the
the um the you know the more instant
facilities policy chairman
um has been approved by the harbour
board
and has been ratified by the community
resources
uh committee um and the whole point the
whole point of the moorings and
facilities policy
is to provide a clear guide to
stakeholders
um and the introduction to that policy
i've clearly stated it will be applied
in a fair
and equitable manner um you know you
employ me
as someone to to to take the decisions
on behalf of the harbor authority
you know with uh with a view to making
changes
my thoughts on it would be that this
policy would come back on its on a two
or three yearly
rotation so we've got the policy in
place now
but like all policies they're under
review
and over the course of time in the next
two or three years
it'll come back to this committee and
then we can pick up on
issues um that that um and john's raised
and that you know
i am very pleased that john has them
well i would just point out that
we've made a decision now over the
period of time and it
is the policy of the heart of the
harvard authority
um but yeah take take on board what
you're saying john i i think it's a very
good idea the idea of facilities but it
is
it's how do you how do you cost and how
can they be afforded
can i speak quickly yes
yes yeah i mean i think what we have to
recognize is that up and down the
bristol channel
ports are investing in yachting
certainly
historically the bristol child the
difficult area to sail
but if you look at areas like portis
head cardiff
swansea um watch it all of these areas
are starting to recognize that
um there are more and more boats around
and certainly on the south coast you
know
it is becoming a very crowded stretch of
water
so i think that perhaps a little bit of
research into what's going on
in the rest of the channel um wouldn't
wouldn't come amidst because
certainly it's a very safe haven bitter
food
and it's a nice place to bring a boat so
it's it's
it's really looking at i mean certainly
the economically
it is unlikely to show a return in the
short term
but i think having dedicated and
relatively simple
facilities for a boat um
would would would be something well
worth considering i mean for example
those facilities actually exist in the
harbor masters office
so it's it's really potentially
extending that
to to encourage boaters to come in and
even a
pond too alongside the key in a
dedicated area and i think this has been
discussed before would enable people to
come alongside
safely and i think coming alongside a
very tall wall with quite slippery [ __ ]
steps is not really conducive to an
enjoyment
but no no i i i agree with you john and
um
you know i think historically
biddeford's a commercial port and
you know the reason why we have so few
leisure vessels
on the north coast is a massive height
rise and fall of tide and the
availability as you say of safe births
in benefit itself and the availability
of ladders
and coming alongside you know what what
what little birthing we do have is
currently taken up with
a number of uh long-term vessels
um could i say some of those are in in
liver boards as well so we're very
restricted
with the amount of space we've got and
commercial births
fishing births and i say these long-term
vessels that have come into the harbor
over
a number of years but if you if we go
further down the
agenda for today you can see that we
that we want to introduce new fees and
charges
and some of those fees and charges are
based around river moorings
and allowing stakeholders to put their
own moorings in
and for us to put moorings in and i
personally is the heart master
i think that's the way we go forward is
we start to lay moorings in the river
and and start to encourage stakeholders
to to
to get involved in taking up those
moorings which is why we've introduced
new charges for the fees and charges the
only other thing i just to pick up on
your point about advertising and
and and advertising
the harbor here we do recognize that our
website
isn't the best website in the world uh
we all know that
but we have an officer on board with tdc
who is working towards
completely revamping um the website
as a harbour authority we've got
significant amounts of paperwork that
needs to go onto that website in
in compliance with the portland safety
code so you will see
next year improvements in the website
and hopefully we will be able to
make improvements to our offer to the
outside world
okay just one more point if i may
one more german um the other point is to
[Music]
register to bit of it as a heritage port
which is something which would actually
assist the status
right we'll move on from that in a
moment councillor rossi
um yeah just uh just a thought the yacht
club have the facilities already john
don't they the um showers and and
everything
perhaps we could just ask the yacht club
what sort of numbers of visitors they
have
they have using their facilities and
then it's quite easy to work it out from
there if they have very few then it's
probably not worth
creating our own facilities you know
yes thank you i was going to suggest
that we ask our officers to do a brief
report
along those lines of how many people
do actually come in at the moment and
i'd like an idea what it's going to cost
bearing in mind the budget meeting we
had at cnr on monday night
where we're already over committed on
the capital budget
so whilst these things sound nice
where's the money coming from
but there we are we must move on item
seven
harbor and pilotage activity called
quarter
free
that's going to be you richard
that's me chairman thank you um
picking up on that um we have added a
slight improvement in a number of ships
uh in the port we had uh um
both ball clay cargos one in october and
one in november
um we have had some uh what i would like
to say is very good news
um our shipyard uh the apple door
shipyard has
been bought by harland and wolfe um
i went to a meeting there with um um
sean carney recently we had a
presentation from uh
harry kennedy the uh acting md for um
harland and wolf belfast and appledore
and they've got they've got big plans
for the shipyard
and it's very very encouraging to see
and i was very impressed with their
professionalism
uh there was a couple of board members
at the presentation
they've got a very strong history of
building ships
and i i i think it's really good news
that um
appledore shipyard is is again up and
running
um chair um the rest of the
report is there before you um i think
the most important thing on that
is the uh the port marine safety code
um i'm currently working with our pilot
um and our designated person janet
williams and obviously the duty holder
which is the
community and resources committee we're
working
through the audit that we recently
received from
our designated person and i can advise
the board
that we will be in a position in march
of next year
to write to the maritime coast guard
agency in compliance with
marine information notice 641 that we
continue to comply with the portland
safety code
um min 641
is a marine information notice that's
just come out from the maritime
coast guard agency and effectively says
that all harbour authorities
before march 2021 must write to them
saying that we are fully compliant with
the portrait safety code and that's
something we're working very hard on at
the moment
over the winter and i can assure the
committee that we will be in a position
the spring of next year for the duty
holder
um which will be your good self sir the
chairman of cnr committee to write that
letter
thank you um i'm happy to answer any
other questions on
on any of the other um items on that
reporter
right throw it open to committee members
or harbour board members technically
sure i think mr gibbs would like to come
in right
come in mr gibbs yeah just a brief
question for paul
the the last ship that came in was for
finland is that a new bit of business
or something that might turn up in the
future
there's one for you i would think paul
i think he's asleep it looks like he's
frozen
sure i know the feeling
is paul speaking from the harbor office
or at home
i think it looks like it's richard's
office
well it's right we can come back to that
richard are you available yeah
i've just phoned richard he that their
computers died so they're just logging
into
another computer so they'll be back with
us shortly
they're both at wescom
thank you councillor christy have you
any comments in the interim
not really just very nice to see a
couple of vessels come in
all right uh out of curiosity does
anyone know
what number of vessels like that it
would take
to break to make the harbor break even
in here
chair sean here i just just jumped on
and i've catching the back end of this
one but when we did
uh the remodeled the stuffing structure
and uh changed the arrangements for the
pilotage we were working on a break even
around
18 ships but they
didn't all
have to come into biddeford because you
obviously get paid some politics
extension money becoming the night yell
under apple door so
that that um that was what we were
looking at there so it's several more
than we've been getting
oh you know that
um i think mr gibbs
are you back on
yes sorry about that chairman my
computer decided to um
throw its hand in an opportune moment
apologies to the committee from that
time
yeah paul tim i i was wondering whether
this ship that came in for the
um the cargo for finland was a new bit
of business is something that might be
sustained
or is it one off
um we have had cargos for finland before
it was very welcome
um i i i honestly can't say with it's a
one-off tim but um we have in the past
had um cargos for nantilly it's a very
um well-known ceramics
um port they do a lot of ceramics in
that area there's some big ceramic
companies so
we have we have delivered to them before
but uh that's a welcome bit of extra
business
thank you just just going on the again
the
this issue of how many ships are
required to break even i think
any number of ships above what we have
at the moment is going to reduce the
deficit isn't it so
that's what we should really be focusing
on
indeed so yes and um you know even
regardless of breaking even tim
you know we are a competent harbor
authority and as i've said in the past
you're very much taught with you we have
other stakeholders
you know the shipyard is very important
for uk plc
the yelland um and the the river tour
depends on the piloted service
the yellen facility also depends on on
on the piloted service so
not only biddeford uh depending on the
pilots we
we we we've got responsibilities to to
other stakeholders importantly the ship
okay
fine job anyone else wishing to comment
on this report
in any shape or form
i think mr puddy would like to convince
you yes
and he comes
there's nobody okay i'm here um thank
you very much
what i was going to say it was um at the
last meeting we
one of the issues around the port is
actually the issue of
um having to get the materials all over
to the
key in one go which is quite a headache
for haulage companies
and the potential of discussing um
[Music]
how to improve that with evan's
transport i wondered if that was
anything that was still ongoing
it's the item which was on act for
action that no actions occurred i think
is the answer sean you've now appeared
you weren't here when we considered
action items the last one
page 11 i think
you're muted sean if you're trying to
speak yeah minute 37
sean yeah i thank you chad no i've not
i've not spoken
i've not spoken to evan since our last
meeting um
it's something we'll have to pick up on
when we've got a better time for that so
yeah noted and we'll get on it
if you would please this is now three
months or
nearly about two three months
anyone else wishing to speak
richard haste very quiet
okay well that report was there for
noting i think we've
noted it uh we now move on to the next
item which will be
fees and charges page 17
who's taking that one that'll be me
chair
so you as requested um
we always present the fees and charges
for the harbor
to the harbour committee um before they
go to cnr
um and you'll see that the charges have
gone up
slightly in line with uh what we've been
advised to do financially
um minimal increases and this also takes
into account what the marketplace
can carry you'll see there as well there
are a number of new ones because
this is the first year that i've i've
done set fees and charges and working
alongside with sean and
and and paul we've we've looked at how
we want to
take harbor forward as the commercial
element
which we're hoping to continue to build
on um
is in the decline at the moment but with
the additional short-term
moorings for leisure facilities and even
commercial
vessels so you see there's a number of
um
new additional charges there um with
pleasure boat mooring charges
for per week and per month instead of
per annum because that may deter
people and also there are um
our own mooring uh river moorings as
well as
um private moorings that are there are
on our thunders
so there are a range and the one that
additional a number of other um ports
charged for and this is something that
we're working through but needed to go
into the fees and charges
if we were to do that following further
consultation
is the percentage charge of fish
basically landed on our uh on our key
and that's set at two percent um
so open for discussion um
if anybody's got any questions right
well
i'll start off from the chair this one
of landing fish
it's per pound value pound money
value i assume how are we going to
police that
well there's an element of trust a
considerable element of trust
and also speaking to paul that um
the ships when they come in we will then
speak to the the
agents and ask for the value of the fish
and and hopefully you know the trust and
the partnership working
will be there and be transparent
it's a difficult one chair but it's
something that other authorities
other harbors achieve through good
working relationships and that's
something that we want to build up in in
benefit
fair enough right throw it open to the
meeting chancellor rossi
uh yeah the um fishing vessel and if
he's
one just to pick up on that again is uh
i just think it should be wavered all
together
as a as a goodwill gesture to the
fishermen who haven't had enough time
already
um i don't think they need to be
charging that cost is
passed on to the end user anyway so i
don't think we need to be paying any
more for our fish because it's bloody
expensive anyway
um so i think it just should be wavered
completely
and uh the other thing was the river
moorings
on under the mooring charges council
laid ones
um would be preferable to every other
private one because then we can maintain
and control the quality of the mooring
i think the private moorings should be
double if not triple the price of the
council late moorings to make it uh
to incentivize the people to use the
council ones instead at least then we
can control them
and control the quality of them
as well
right who's going to comment to that i
fully understand what you're saying
councillor rossi
um chairman i could come on that uh
um friendly
no fishing vessel does land to benefit
harvard
most of them are atlanta appledore so
this will not
be an additional burden to our fishing
fleet
our current fishing fleet will not be
additionally burdened
they currently land to our other
facility
in appledore and so perhaps there's a
conversation to be had there in the
future with the fishing community about
how that's going to work in appledore
currently
fishing vessels don't normally land to
biddeford it's something that we
we've started we've had uh inquiries
from
uh vessels outside of biddeford and it's
something that we've introduced to
to pick up on visiting fishing vessels
with regards to the
moorings council i hear what you say but
the research that we've done recently
into other ports and particularly local
ports
they all of them do it this way round
with a lower
charge for self-laid moorings and then a
higher charge
for council moorings so we've we've just
really gone along with
with what what with the industry norm
really
counsellor um and and uh
says it's a new it's a new child
well uh just to come back on that paul
um we don't have to be the same as
everyone else
you know i just think i think keeping
control of the moorings i know what
quality moorings are correct
you know um i think
putting our own moorings in is better
for the council better for us as a
harbor authority because we will make
more money in the long run
and i think trying to persuade people to
use our facilities instead of putting
their own in
uh will be advantageous to us in the
long run
so i mean that's my point anyway i think
you should
at least double if not triple the prices
of the private ones and
make people we'll incentivize them to
use ours instead
uh there you go councillor christie
yeah can i i've got two questions can i
just follow up councillor rossi
on my agenda it says river moorings
private moorings on
tdc funders what does that actually mean
um so within the harbour authority
jurisdiction
um we have the right to lay moorings
and we have the right under our
legislation to make charges
um
the river torridge in its entirety
including the new key ridge um
the fundus is rented by torres district
council
from the crown estate so
we through our renting of the fundus
from the crown estate
in in the entirety of the river torrid
we have the powers to lay moorings
all right so does that mean we can
charge the yacht club
or what
um with regards to the yacht club um
councillor um we have been in
discussions with a lot
yacht club last year myself and
councillor rossi
and our independent advisor tim gibbs
had a number of
meetings with the yacht club that
weren't
very successful we
we then decided that we were going to
take further advice
from the representative of the crown
estate with regards to the fundus in the
river
and that is it is an ongoing issue
that the pandemic has got in the way of
but um yes it's it's on our radar sir
thank you and uh the other question was
about the church field and riverbanks
sitway charges where this is one launch
only
are we talking about jet skis as well as
boats here
uh yes sir it's any any any any vessel
that's um
any any vessel right
right because councillor ford you recall
reckons a lot of people don't bother
paying uh i'm not sure
how we measure that but uh the launch
speed doesn't look very large anyway
it's a chair i can come back on that one
if you'd like yeah
it's picked up through the uh so the
with there used to be a slipway warden
uh ecuador there isn't a slipway warden
anymore
the fee is paid through the pay and
display machine and it's enforced by the
parking enforcement officers
um they probably don't catch every
uh person who launches because they're
not there all the time
the tides don't correspond with their
working hours so we said we're certainly
not catching everybody
but when uh you looked back and i think
it was about 2014 actually
just the last year that the slipway
warden worked on church fields
um it it didn't break even cost wise so
there weren't we were
it was actually costing us as a council
and the other thing with that was
we were and i have discussed this with
councillors ford and haynes who were
very keen to control the
launching of jet skis we were advised at
that time
by um uk port advisors they were called
to not uh charge those launch fees or
have a slipway wouldn't because that by
that
very act we're almost seen to be
condoning and
taking management responsibilities for
slipways sorry um
jet skis on the estuary so we we sort of
backed off of that
um those charges actually aren't
something that you
can vary they would need to be varied by
the
park changing the parking order
so they're produced to us now it was an
after the lord mere show job
you you chair can recommend um a change
to cnr and cnr can recommend the change
to the parking order
that needs advertising and god knows
what then does it
it does yeah
and the parking orders recently been
done or being done
no we'll be changing the parking order
in the new year because
uh assuming the uh there's no calling
and amendment to the decision made on
monday night about campervans we'll need
to change the park in order to
change the charges on for the campervans
on churches
so if the harbour board looked up today
and said we're not happy with this we
want variations it could be included in
the
current one absolutely ah
right councillor christie any comments
none at all really no it sounds very
interesting
do you want to make a proposal along the
line anywhere
well the only discussion i've heard is
uh on monday was about
camper vans it wasn't about jet skis so
i'm not quite certain what
uh counselors forward and how you
informed to do it
no uh counselor rossi you got any
comments you were raising queries on
some of these
charges for the jet ski ones
no i don't think so i mean
we'll we'll leave it in lens hands i
think
okay and things like the fish charge
that doesn't come under the parking
order anyway does it
oj that's that's that's a harbor charge
so
um your other charges are you're free to
recommend because
essentially what richard's presented
here is is it is a draft proposal for
you to recommend
as part of the budget setting process if
you want to recommend changes then
that's
that's fine all right councillor rossi
over to you well can we recommend that
we do
do change the um uh
the river moorings in the private and
the um council laid ones i mean is there
does
any does anybody agree with me that it
would be better for us to
um have people using our moorings
instead of putting in their own
people agree with that
well it certainly sounds better to me
but um
i'm i've got a boat and i don't go on
the river but um
can i ask are the privately laid ones
are they
just as good as ours they ca or how do
they actually lay them does the harbour
master tell them where they can go or
what
what do they just turn up well i've laid
quite a few myself for various people
and it can be anything from an old
anchor with a piece of chain that's not
suitable or not fit for purpose
um or john john will be able to tell you
about moorings down there or probably
tim as well i mean it can be
anything an old lump of iron or a car
tire or anything you like filled with
concrete i mean there's no
stipulation there's no um rules of what
you can put down there so
in my mind it would be better to have
you know have something that surveyed
and looked at and maintained and
you know that we can look after
ourselves
that would be better well having heard
that i think i agree with councillor
rossi
yeah i'd like to hear from
mr gibbs or mr buddy on this one
actually i i don't have any comment on
that i wanted to talk about the harbour
charges
okay if if i may then um
when i first came here which is many
years ago i went to the harbour master
who was in vernon harris
and said i'd like to lay a mooring down
in appledore
and vernon very sensibly
told me exactly what to do and what the
requirements were for a safe mooring
and i've i very much respected the fact
that there was
there appeared to be a system and he
pointed to a spot
where he thought i would be okay to put
a mooring down and i thought that was a
really good way of controlling
in an amicable way where people where
people put
moorings down one of the issues is that
people just plonk
moorings down wherever they like and if
you look outside our house here you'll
see there's
the river is littered with abandoned
moorings which are a real hazard to
shipping
and boaters and a lot of people
inadvertently pick these things up and
end up drifting down the river and in
the last couple of weeks i've seen three
boats just
drift past our hanks and so i think
regarding what councilor ross is saying
there's a very good point in
in terms of putting down a trot mooring
or a council owned mooring
or at least setting a standard
for moorings and also advising on the
um the locations of moorings just just
to keep
a sensible system of where people can
more where they can
more safely and more importantly to keep
them out of the fairway
just on the launching facilities
since we lost the warden um i think it's
been a really sensible system in the
sense that you have to pay
not only for your vehicle but for the
trailer
which means you pay a double parking
charge
and that's impossible to
to to get away with because you've got a
very obvious vehicle and a trailer
the only thing i would suggest is that
the trailer should be
marked with the vehicle registration
number
because the two tickets that are bought
from the machine relate to one vehicle
and the vehicle is not always part with
the trailer
because in busy days you have to find
two places
and so as i think there are simple
things that could be done to
dramatically improve
the situation in biddeford bearing in
mind it's a very popular place
so i mean benefit and appledore very
popular place to launch and i think it's
another
element of interest for tourists and
it's a very nice estuary to come into so
we want to make it attractive and
relatively easy
this is crossing the bar or was in there
um we've talked around it
there's a degree of sympathy can i have
a formal proposal if you wish to
please
councillor rossi i'm really looking to
you ah is this to um
up the uh charges for the uh private
moorings is
is that what we're talking about charges
for the private moorings or
switch them around or whatever i would
personally if
i'm going to recommend that we triple
the price and put it up to 90 quid
for a private mooring and make it uh
lot more appetizing for them to have
armoring instead
so i would propose that we triple the
value of the
private mooring
i know where you're coming from the one
question
if we put down the mooring do we have a
liability
i'm looking to stacy on that one
yes chair we do and the the other
question that was going through
my mind as this has been presented i
don't know how many um
council moorings we actually have and if
it would mean having to put more in and
the cost in relation to that
um i think paul would be able to give us
more information but certainly if we
put down moorings that that is our
liability i don't know what the cost of
that mooring is
i don't know where we can put the
moorings i don't know what we've already
got in place in relation to private
moorings so
i think um councillor rossi's
is interesting but i i just don't have
the facts and figures to be able to kind
of give a
adequate answer as i understand it we
have very kind of limited places that we
can actually put moorings in as well
and i know the ones that we have put in
thus far
have been extremely expensive we're
talking thousands of pounds and i'm
i'm not going to begin to understand the
complications behind it all
um paul can you add anything to
how many council moorings do we have
uh thank you stacy uh currently we don't
have any uh council laid moorings um
i think this is something if you want we
can bring back
as another report and more detail report
on costings and prices and
and we could we could um
scrub these two more into an hour and
then and bring bring back a report to
the next committee or
next year and uh bring a more detailed
financial report
and um in support of councillor rossi's
um arguments for increased warnings and
and give you some more detailed
uh breakdowns if the chairman wants to
do that we can we can do that
um i have a question for stacey i think
um
sorry sorry uh but do we do we have a
liability if if the private moorings are
placed on our thunders
i mean if somebody comes and plonks
something on your land are you liable
for what they've done
you know do is that is that something
yeah thanks councilman i mean i i i
think
this is part of the reason why paul has
brought
forward the moorings policy i think
moorings and facilities policy i think
we are accepting that that there are
difficulties with the harbour and we
need to get some some structure there
um and why we're looking to put formal
agreements etcetera in place
because certainly we don't offer
facilities as
as it stands in the harbour at the
moment
and we've had votes come in that we
weren't necessarily aware of so it
it is trying to put those
responsibilities back look if you're
mooring in
in the harbor it's over to you it's your
responsibility
and and i think i think paul will agree
um the reason why
the policy's been put forward is because
we
we know we've had difficulties certainly
in the past and mr puddy's just just
said
pre you know in relation to boats just
floating down the river et cetera we
need to kind of start
getting um to grips with with the harbor
the charges everything else i mean i've
heard today that your discussion
regarding
um the facilities etc it's been very
hard for us to introduce
um proper charges because we don't have
proper facilities
neither do we provide the proper
facilities at the moment so literally if
people want
more the responsibility is over to them
at the moment
and i think members will appreciate and
councillor hicks
um alluded to it earlier the capital
program that we have
thus far is is way over um
overspent and there's going to be some
difficult decisions to make going
forward
and the capital report is going to be
coming to full council shortly
and in january um we're going to have to
start budget setting
so i mean all of this stuff can of
course be done
um but members are going to have to
start deciding what what is the
priorities in relation to this and when
i hear about
introducing um council moorings you know
that that that could certainly be a
substantial cost as well
um i just uh just one
query then so if we charge
for private moorings on our funders we
become responsible anyway
because we're charging them correct no
no no no no with no responsibility yeah
yeah the response and that's why we'll
look to put formal agreements in place
so we charge them for mooring but we
don't provide any facilities the
responsibility is down to the individual
boat owners
okay so if it goes in light and the boat
washes off down the river it ain't our
fault
right
i think councillor rossi my gut feeling
is
i've got a lot of sympathy with what
you're saying but to
fiddle around with it at this stage
we're too much in the dark to do it
we've got some advice which has only got
to run for 12
months and in the interim we can have in
good time a proper report
with costings with liabilities
and then we can weigh it up properly
okay yeah i agree with you there bob i
think i mean obviously there must have
been some costings to come up with these
prices in the beginning
whatever they were
but uh maybe not maybe they were just uh
in evaluation in the valuation world we
use the daraby method
there would be about right all right
yeah
i think that's what's applicable here
right yeah yeah mr gibbs would like to
come in
yes yeah can i go back to harvard
charges
i think we need to understand more about
the play business
um what we're proposing here is
for a clay boat coming in the charges
will be about two pounds sixty two pound
fifty seven
a ton do we know how much value has
attacked those cargoes what the
transport costs are
so we can get some idea of where our
charge is laying the scheme of things
um chairman no we don't have any any
information as to
what what other operators are charging
for transport costs and
um outside of our own business i think
we ought to
i think it's you know our costs are
relevant but
we're sort of floundering around the
dark really we have no idea what sort of
percentage
of the total cost of the business to
them is
i i think mr gibbs the problem we have
is that
we'll never get the true cost it's
largely
covered up by the holiers
who argue that it's cheaper to haul into
tin must than it is into biddeford with
the problems of loading and unloading
and that
the the figures get confused whenever
you try and make an effort i think it's
impossible to get there that's my
understanding
am i wrong well i
it must be impossible and that's
absolutely correct sir
yeah it must be possible for someone to
have a a reasonable idea
of what the transport the real transport
cost is like to be
not necessarily what they charge but
what the real transport cost is
the best bet for that is this meeting we
got scheduled
the best bet for that is this meeting
we've got scheduled with john evans
i rest my case yes
which is something certainly we can
raise can't we sean
i think this is a more important issue
than the issues we're talking about
uh private moorings
they're all important in their way
sure yeah yes it's definitely something
we can pick up with john evans i i know
um
the last i i don't know whether he was
um joff was on the port security meeting
earlier
and mentioned i think john is out of the
country
um for for a few weeks um perhaps we set
if i set up a zoom or something like
that with him and nigel
for the first weeks in the new year
would that suit you chair
yep right fine that's what i do
chancellor christie
chancellor christie i think he's just
left his desk chair
he's right sorry there's somebody on the
door i thought it was a cat
yeah there's a cat as well sorry we've
just finished that bit
can i ask your hand was up to me chris
councillor christie
sorry your hand was up that's why
yes what it was was um very briefly we
just mentioned that
um we lease uh the river from the crown
commissioners i think
where we have a lease on it can i ask
how much do we pay the crown
commissioners per year
you want me to assist chair yeah please
yeah it's one pound a year um it's more
of a liability for them so we
we lease it and then we take
responsibility so it's uh
a quid pro quo so we don't theoretically
pay anything councillor christie but we
do win
um maintaining the shorelines etcetera
does that does that include the reserve
bank car park because i thought we had
to pay for that
yeah it includes all of that i can i can
you can have a copy of the lease and the
plan
attached to it if you want it's quite
fast
to welcome yeah i think it's very good
value
chancellor rossi yeah just
sorry stacy could you could you send me
that um
as well could you email that across to
me for me to have a look
yeah absolutely i'll leave a link to all
all harbour board
so i think we end up
noting item eight
would be the way it's drifted down but
we want a lot more
information on certain things for the
next meeting
chair i think there's a i think the way
this will have to work
for reasons of timing is that if you uh
effectively if you note the the report
those fees and charges will have to go
into the budget setting process
in advance of your next meeting so
you're effectively saying
that this is what you're accepting for
fees and charges
um and obviously you can review them for
next year
i guess other things might be picked up
through
uh community and resources or through
full council when the budget is set
i suppose that would be your other
opportunity to vary any fees and charges
but i think next year i'd like to see
this on the agenda earlier
so that where we've got queries they can
be looked into
and we can put more thought to the
setting of the charges
it's chair richard can arrange that
that's fine doesn't i i guess you
schedule it for a meeting
before yeah yeah i can do that chair
and just to reiterate what we said you
know these are a number of new charges
and and taking over the service and just
having a an overview
in the short time is something that we
want to generate more income and
obviously the moorings themselves do not
actually include the material required
that would be on a separate but this is
only for
the fees and charges per annum that we
put in so
you know if you would like those for
this to be taken out and members would
want more detail then that's fine
um not a problem at all i can take them
home that's what i take them out that's
what the discussion was for
proper job
any other business
if there is no other business then i'm
good oh council
rossi wanting to speak yeah me again
sorry
um just a question i don't know if it's
uh
for us or not but there's paul might
know actually there's a
small slip way along from um
what's anthony glover's uh bit of ground
he's got there along from the fish dock
i think it's called the iron yard or
some yard there and there's a small
slipway
near there and there's lots and lots of
waste and rubbish and
junk and stuff is being dumped in there
i'm wondering if
if that's our problem do we own this or
or what
somebody answer that
i i don't know chairman i'm sorry i
can't help you
so check can i just clarify with
councillor rossi is this the slipway
that sits between
uh new key and middle dock
no sorry yeah nuclear middle dog
not i'm not quite sure sean it's the
it's only a small slip way and it's
what's the name of that place there
anthony glover's got the yard there
um whether you know that piece or not
it's uh
i think i think i know what you mean i
think you're on about the one the one
just the other side of our fish dock
between yes
hubba stone that hubba stone so you got
the fish dock and then you go on to what
the land that belongs to the uh the
shipyard it's a ship yeah
yeah yeah so it's the shipyard owns that
slipway yeah
yeah interesting okay there's just a lot
of it's accumulated a lot of rubbish
there now there's a lot of people
dumping stuff there and
a lot of some of it is going into the
river as well so
it needs to be addressed i guess
okay councillor christie
yeah i can't just say thank you to sean
um i did have comments about the state
of bank end where the house boats were
putting their gas bottles on the
uh river bank and all sorts and it has
been cleared up
um i'm not sure if you did go down and
have a word but there is still a kind of
outside
seating area made of old pallets down
there but can i ask about the boats
um for that they're right next to the
houseboats
there's an old barge and there's two
other vessels there
do we know who owns them and are they
paying us any more in charges or
anything
or are they just being dumped
it is my ward i should say yeah that's
one for paul
as far as i'm aware this this is the
boat that's been referred to as the old
concrete boat or something there's other
vessels there i i think they're paying
hop um mooring fees but paul will tell
you
thank you council there's one vessel
there that's paying um
uh and bring charges in the space
two or three peoples are the best that
we
bought over the bronze wharf uh project
um originally
they did have those owners have faded
into
the background and not been able to
contact them
of late
sorry paul we've struggled to hear that
could you say that again for the
committee
yeah there's one boat there the uh the
open boat um
which is um alongside uh the berth
that vessel is paying harbor jews the
other two or three
uh yachts and other boats there they
were vessels that we've brought over
from brunswick war for the brunswick war
project and they
originally there was owners attached to
those vessels
but the owners have since disappeared
and not been able to get hold of them
so that's boats for scrapping in due
course then is it
okay i mean yes those votes they'll
disappear in due course i'll i'll i can
look at putting a notice on those and
uh but again it's a cost isn't it it's
cost implications you
you've got to go through the process of
trying to get hold of the owners and
then
putting the notices on them and then
it's
it's another cost implication
right any other business
before i declare the meeting close can i
ask the officers to look into
internet zoom connections it's been very
difficult today to hear paul and richard
they do need to have improved
connections in some shape or form or
moved to a different venue
it's not satisfactory what we've had
today
not their fault it's the machinery fault
of no doubt
any other business i'll declare the
meeting closed at 3
33 thank you for your attendance
goodbye